[Music]
touken we are running out of time
if you don't let me cheat off you I'm
gonna tell your parents that you stopped
like heads in the theatre without them I
didn't see black panther in the theatre
of course you did token that's why me
riffing on it pissed you off so much I
swear on my mother's life I don't care
what you said about Black Panther
goodbye token I don't understand if you
didn't see it and you really don't care
that I ripped on Black Panthers then why
would you let me cheat oh my god you
don't care what I said because you did
see it and you didn't like it either huh
that's what this is all about isn't it
you hate yourself for seeing through the
Mirage like I did and that's why you
wouldn't let me cheat off you well I
didn't write Black Panther token it
isn't my fault it's not why go after me
but now it's over don't worry they're
not gonna know you didn't like Black
Panther so long as you never make me
fail another math test well we're
probably both gonna fail now because
fourth-period already started what no
come on we did it
[Music]
[Applause]
you